foreign
CBS morning's deals where we share items
that might make your day a little bit
better a little brighter as well all at
exclusive discounts and during women's
History Month which is a month we're in
right now we are sharing some products
from women-owned businesses to start
shopping right now all you got to do is
scan the QR code from your screen don't
even need to get up in fact or visit
cbsdeals.com meantime lifestyle expert
Elizabeth Werner joins us now thank you
very much for being here thanks for
having me I'm wowed by this charging get
up here because I just found this is a
shelf yes with a plug that's right it's
a socket shelf okay a lot of a lot of
s's in there but this is great so you
have one outlet that then becomes eight
six AC Outlets two USBS and it's got a
shelf no installation all you do is just
plug it in and then you have all of this
you can charge all your devices so for
me in the kitchen I might put my tablet
or my phone up do my recipes you could
put your little things up we're in the
bathroom now all of a sudden you can use
this little shelf here so you can put
your toothbrush that you actually have
to charge so my son lives in department
and he has no access to outlets one's
behind the bed one he only has one so
now we turn that into eight he could
plug everything in right around his desk
so six Outlets somewhere on the side
somewhere in the front this is a
must-have you think about the bathroom
the laundry room out in the garage out
downstairs in your little workshop area
so I just love this and this right now
is just twenty dollars 33 off wow this
is life-changing when you move this into
your room all right this is arts and
crafts come play come play all right I
want you to grab a marker I I can turn
these on this is egg amazing the egg
decorator so now think of when you're
decorating eggs at home oh my God you've
got the smelly vinegar you've got the
dyes everything gets everywhere the kids
are a mess you have stuff on your hands
look how easy this is Katie we're doing
this at Teddy's birthday look at this
this is the best little thing for kids
for parents and I love so the original
one here this was on Shark Tank by the
way the original one looked like this
Little Egg now they have the bunny they
have the dinosaur so lots of really fun
options take the stink and the mess out
of decorating and the price I love yes
so this is 17.99 it's 36 off and look at
what we've done very pretty they're
gorgeous yes a lot of fun all right so
this is such an important safety device
it's called invisaware this is from a
woman-owned business we're so excited
this is Raja abdelaziz and she came up
with this device after she herself was
followed by men in a van who were
yelling at her this actually has on the
back a button you push the button twice
and it's going to send an alert to five
of your friends or family members if
you're in trouble if you're in trouble
you can whether you're in trouble
whether you have a medical condition so
my daughter my son and I all have a
medical condition we're weak faint and
we feel it coming on we push this twice
it alerts people and it also tells them
where they are it's the GPS very handy
yes great products I love
Elizabeth Warner thank you very much we
packed a lot in there and of course we
do partner with all of these companies
to get these incredible deals you want
to buy something you saw today scan the
QR code on your screen or visit
cbsdeals.com
don't even have to get up we'll be right
back that does it for us actually no
we're going bye see you tomorrow